you're Asian that's why you're skinny
well it's so easy to simply generalize
and assume that all agents are skinny
but are we really the truth is not all
Asians are skinny especially with our
fast-paced life and also convenient diet
nowadays however if you were to compare
an average American to an average Asian
we are still slimmer in size and no it
is not 100% genetics it has a lot to do
with your lifestyle and also your food
intake so let's dive deeper and take a
look at a typical Asian diet and why we
are naturally slimmer the main focus of
an Asian diet is to create wellness and
to live healthier it is not a short term
fat diet the whole point is to create
balance and also moderation which is
something I truly believe in so for the
purpose of this video I'm going to take
a look at the East Asian diet the first
reason is we prefer tea or water over
soft drinks if you were to go to a
Chinese restaurant the first thing the
waiter will ask you is what type of tea
do you prefer and most restaurants will
offer tea or water for free I remember
when I was living in the UK and whenever
I dine out I would ask for a warm cup of
water and most of the time the waiter
will give me a surprised look on two
occasions the waiter told me that I was
the first person to have ever asked for
just plain warm water so Chinese
typically prefer one tea or water over
soft drinks drinking tea or water fills
you up on zero calories and it helps to
support your digestive system now if you
were to drink soft drinks together with
your meals you will be filling up on
auntie and bad calories which can lead
to weight gain over time reason number
two our portions are smaller and we use
chopsticks people tend to eat what they
are served
hence larger portions can lead to
overeating even when you're not hungry
if you have been to Asia I'm sure the
first thing you would notice are the
food portions generally portion servings
are smaller in Asia
compared to Western countries Asians are
also accustomed to family-style dining
which means we enjoy a huge variety of
dishes shared by everyone instead of
worrying about needing to finish that
huge plate of food we're more concerned
about finishing our bowl of rice while
enjoying a little bit of everything in
bite-size portions plus the practice of
eating with chopsticks means you will
eat less and feel full quicker that's
because when you use chopsticks you will
take smaller mouthfuls slowing down your
speed of eating allowing your body to
digest better and sending the signal to
your brain to stop eating when you are
full so you will avoid overeating
stuffing yourself with so much food the
next reason is we enjoy real food not
processed food cooking and eating real
food is still a very huge part of the
Asian diet everywhere you go in Asia
eating freshly cooked street food is
easily accessible and it is very cheap
on a daily basis we eat rice or noodles
served with a huge variety of vegetables
meat or fish instead of having processed
junks such as burgers hot dogs fries or
pizza I remember the first time I saw my
friend warming up frozen ready meals in
the UK I genuinely thought that he was
preparing food for his dog without
realising that was for our dinner I've
never seen frozen ready meals prior to
that and you can just simply put it into
the microwave and it's ready within 5
minutes coming from Asia I was so used
to eating freshly cooked warm food
processed food and convenient ready
meals are typically loaded with fat
sodium sugar and they pack lot calories
if you eat them on a regular basis you
will feel hungry crave for more bad food
and you will gain weight over time on
the other hand eating real food
that's freshly cooked will provide your
body with good nutrients it will eat
proper digestion keeping you full and
you will stay slim for life the next
point is we eat on time most agents
typically have their breakfast between
8:00 to 9:00 a.m. there lunch between
chopped
1 p.m. and their dinner between 6 to 8
p.m. now if they missed one of the three
important meals they can feel cranky
tired jig and feel like a huge part of
their routine is missing and they can
even feel really shitty about it that
sounds like me now if you're someone who
eats on a go chances are you will make
poor food choices because you would just
grab whatever that's available at that
moment in time and you don't have
control over your food you can't a snack
a lot more on calories dense food as
well just to give you the energy to keep
going if you notice agents don't really
snack
in fact snacking is not really part of
our culture we have a set meal routine
and we enjoy eating three wholesome
meals this can prevent hunger pangs or -
snacking or overeating on your next meal
next we agents take our meal time very
seriously when it is Meal Time it is
Meal Time and nothing else that means
taking a break and going for lunch with
your friends at a restaurant or having
dinner with a family around the dining
table not in front of the TV or your
computer while watching your favorite TV
show mealtime is Meal Time this practice
helps us to eat more mindfully as we are
fully present and fully engaged with our
food and nothing else now when you eat
with distractions you tend to eat a lot
more when our brain is so focused on
other things such as working on a laptop
or watching that TV show your body can't
register the feeling of satisfaction and
you will eat at least 30% more now if
you were to stay slim without even
trying just be fully present with your
food trust me you will feel satisfied
quicker and your food would taste so
much better reason number six we enjoy
soups I recently came across this
statement when eating fill your body
with 50 percent food 25 percent liquid
and keep the remaining 25% for digestion
there is so much of truth in this
statement in my previous video I shared
ten reasons why soups can help
great loss so if you want to know more
about the benefits of adding soups into
your diet do check it out
soup or a soup based dish is present in
almost every Asian meal for instance
congee is a very common breakfast to
have in Asia I personally love soup
noodles soup fills you up very quick on
very little calories and it is packed
with nutrients and also vitamins so if
you can start adding soups into your
diet you can have it as a starter or as
a main meal and you will notice that you
will have less throughout the day or
even for your other meals I'm talking
about broth based or vegetable soups not
those heavy cream loaded soups
also we agents enjoy a lot more
fermented foods fermented foods such as
Mesa Tempe kombucha soy sauce and acid
kimchi act as natural probiotics keeping
your gut healthy and they will also help
with proper digestion our gut is also
known as our second brain if your gut
isn't functioning at its optimum level
no matter how well you eat your body
will not be able to fully absorb all the
nutrients hence it would just go to
waste
so adding fermented food into your diet
can lead to weight loss especially
visceral fat accumulated around the
abdominal organs if you want to know
more about your gut health and how it is
linked to weight loss do watch my video
right here next our desserts are
nutritious let's face it most of us like
it to end our meal with something sweet
chocolate ice cream cakes perhaps well
if you were to dine in a Chinese
Japanese or Korean restaurants chances
are at the end of the meal they will
serve you with fruits fruits equal
dessert those sugary Scaggs sweets or
chocolates are treats and they are only
served for special occasions the
traditional Chinese soup desserts or
also known as Tong sway are very
nutritious and they have healing
properties for instance sweet potato
ginger soup barley soup or red bean soup
in Asia these desserts are widely
consumed after
miel this leads on to my final point we
use food as medicine if you're ill
modern medical care will simply
prescribe you with antibiotics without
getting to the root of the problem but
this pill and you should feel fine
within the next few hours now
traditional Chinese medicine will get
down to the root of the problem and they
will prescribe you with herbal
medication to rebalance your body's
system if you have visited a hobo shop
before you will find hundreds of herbs
that are used for healing purposes herbs
and spices are also at the very heart of
Asian cooking healthy spices such as
cinnamon turmeric ginger coriander and
chili are widely used in Asian dishes
and they have tremendous healing
properties such as increasing metabolism
reducing blood pressure and also
cholesterol levels you don't need to eat
Asian food every day to be healthy you
can still enjoy your cuisines and
practice these principles so eat a lot
of vegetables eat a huge variety of food
eat more real food and less processed
food drink more tea or water and reduce
on your sugary drinks and eat mindfully
okay it is all about moderation and
creating balance too much or too little
of any one thing is not good so I hope
this video has given you some insight
and also useful tips in regards to the
Asian diet which you can start adopting
what other tips do you press this to
stay healthy do let me know in the
comments below don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot of nutritional and also fitness tips
do turn on your notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best